hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 27th of August today and you're
watching games but you let's do the
thing where I tell you some stuff if
you're one of the relatively small
minority who are actually a fan of the
kinect then you may want to know that
the standalone version is coming on
october seven the peripheral which i
promise to stop jokingly referring to as
an NSA spy camera will be a hundred and
fifty bucks and is shipping with a
digital copy of dance central spotlight
no word yet on if you'll be able to buy
the camera without the game but given
that the dancing title is only retailing
for 10 bucks I think we can assume it's
just a freebie Microsoft has continued
to voice their support of the device
saying Xbox one is better with Kinect
the company also announced that since
the $400 connect lyst Xbox one launched
demand for the five-hundred-dollar
bundle with Kinect has actually
increased mario kart 8 is getting too
sweet DLC packs which among other things
incorporate the legend of zelda and
animal crossing each pack is retailing
to seven dollars 99 individually or 1299
together and you can pre-order now if
you want snagging yourself immediate
access to multicolored Yoshi's and shy
guys all up there will be six new
characters eight new vehicles and 16 new
crosses spread across the DLC packs new
tracks include ones inspired by f-zero
excitebike animal crossing and warriors
woods The Legend of Zelda pack which
launches in November contains Lincoln
Tanooki Mario and cat peach as
characters while the Blue Falcon from f0
is a new fancy drivable cut the second
animal crossing pack which comes out in
may of next year includes villager
Isabel and dry Bowser you can check out
all the awesome images on site in super
weird the potentially kind of cool news
Dragon Age Inquisition is going to have
multiplayer Bioware confirmed through
IGN that Inquisition will facilitate up
to floor player co-op the mode which is
completely separate to the single-player
mode is designed to be played in 20 to
30 minute sessions and amounts to 3
multiplayer campaigns made up of
randomized events that occur within a
large level divided into small
the sections 12 heroes across three
classes are being made available in this
mode and bioware a promising plenty of
DLC for the multiplayer fans out there
the completion of quests in this mode
will give you Gold's that you can spend
on treasure chests containing all kinds
of loot while the DLC is all going to be
free there will be the opportunity to
purchase the games virtual currency to
speed up your progress but Bioware
producers silico star is promising
nothing is behind a paywall last up
today it's in no way something we
haven't heard before but a metro Redux
developer is sounding off on the power
of the ps4 almost [ __ ] coughs tov 4a
games chief technical officer and men
whose name i will continue to embarrass
myself trying to say has said that the
ps4 is just a bit more powerful given
the xbox one's lower compute unit count
and memory bandwidth he told the dual
foundry that even though there are
limitations to Microsoft's box counting
pixels may not be the best way to assess
which console is better explaining we
may push forty percent more pixels per
frame on ps4 but it's not forty percent
better as a result your own eyes can
tell you that he made the point that
just because the ps4 is more powerful
now does not mean it will stay that way
the reason being that Microsoft are
continuing to improve their Xbox
development kits and he expects that
this could make it different and as for
your question of the day let me know
which mario kart 8 edition you're most
excited for that is it for me for today
be sure to leave me all your thoughts on
today's stories and join me same time
tomorrow for a bunch more news